[Musik]
sie rennen für die demokratie wenn es
sein muss bis zur erschöpfung
[Musik]
sprinter proben die wir hier machen es
hat ganz oft was auch vom leistungssport
sie durchleben höhen ich habe natürlich
positiv das ganz große freue mich
wahnsinnig darauf und tiefen
fertig sein
rock in whistler sie versuchen den
dialog dass ich nicht beherrschen kann
und ernten dafür manchmal hat sie wollen
politik machen in sehr bewegten zeiten
mir persönlich ist schon auch langsam
richtig an die nerven
irgendwas ist einfach eine schwierige
zeit abgeordnete im 19
deutschen bundestag noch nie gab es so
viele und selten waren sie so auf dem
prüfstand
wie gehen sie damit um ein parlament in
der bewährungsprobe
wie steht es um die demokratie in
deutschland zwei jahre lang haben wir
sechs abgeordnete begleitet 6 von 709
aus jeder fraktion eine oder ein
gemeinsames merkmal ihr nachname
müller
[Musik]
es beginnt zwei wochen nach der wahl
frank müller rosentritt ordnet sein
neues leben
er ist jetzt mitglied des bundestages
das hotel zahlt er von der diät ein büro
gibt es noch nicht es ist ein katapult
staat also das gibt es war sie ohne
kurzfrist sofort nur am ende das auch
dass leute finden das ist halt eben
losgeht
bisher arbeitete er für eine bank war
dabei ein unternehmen aufzubauen
der sprung nach berlin kommt plötzlich
der wiedereinzug der fdp unerwartet
stark nach den ersten hochrechnungen war
es für mich ganz klar das ist für mich
nicht 3 und ich habe ihn einfach gefragt
nach den ganzen wahlkampf einen
regulierten zurück zur arbeit zu gehen
meine familie meinen mein leben zu leben
doch zurück geht es erstmal nicht müller
rosentritt ist jetzt volksvertreter
einer den sie im bundestag erst noch
kennenlernen müssen
[Musik]
auch neu dabei hansjörg müller
unternehmensberater aus bayern jetzt
abgeordneter der asd
im wahlkampf hatte er gewettert gegen
die da oben die politik elite spannung
steigt jetzt gehört er selbst dazu
dokumente dokumente b und dokumente c
seit zwei wochen geht das so so wie
früher als student ja wahlkampf
natürlich gesagt wir wollen die
polit-elite ablösen die wir empfinden
als vom volke abgehoben und dem volke
nicht mehr so die nennt wie es sein soll
und soll ich das eines tages werden dann
habe ich dann habe ich keine
existenzberechtigung mehr im bundestag
zu schaffen
zwei mitarbeiter hat müller schon und
gute laune haben durchgehend ja hier
auch ganz ganz interessant die
sitzordnung im deutschen bundestag
ganz geheim da wurde er sehr viel drüber
berechnet wo wir jetzt sitzen und wir
irgendwie nicht neben uns sitzen will
die kamera steht doch hier besitzen
linksaußen ich sage besser laufen können
wieder waren schuss ins knie vom
politischen gegner
das freut uns doch und auch er ist neu
immerhin sieht müller von der cdu
übernimmt schon mal ein fertiges büro
mit 28 jahren ist er einer der jüngsten
im neuen bundestag
[Musik]
bankkaufmann aus sachsen anhalt nach dem
wahlkampf heißt es jetzt warten auf
einen sitz im ausschuss warten bis
endlich eine regierung steht ja ich kann
es formulieren das nervt halt ein
bisschen dass es halt so lange dauert
aber zu dauert demokratie einerseits gut
aber andererseits will man ja auch was
bewegen
[Musik]
ganz in der nähe von seinem
bundestagsbüro hat müller eine bleibe
auch sie übernommen vom ausgeschiedenen
abgeordneten
[Musik]
hier wird er gut ein drittel des jahres
wohnen immer dann wenn in berlin
sitzungswoche ist ja das ist das ganz
kleine reiche in das neuen abgeordneten
sehr spartanisch vollkommen ausreichend
es gibt eine zwei lampen einmal wieder
hinten wenn ich nachts jetzt noch lese
ich habe mir auch den haushalt ich bin
dann noch ein bisschen kommunalpolitisch
aktiv und da gibt es jetzt den haushalt
für das nächste jahr die werde ich jetzt
nachts noch studieren
daher reicht die lampe selbst werde ich
auch noch lampen anbringen
mein vorgänger auf gänzlich verzichtet
weil man abends einfach 22 23 uhr dann
auch nur noch zu bett geht in der regel
jetzt ist ein bisschen zeit jedoch ohne
zweifel 13 heißt ich kann auch anders
machen noch den haushalt durch arbeiten
und dann feierabend ist überaus bett das
werden die familie da ist wird man hier
gemeinsam übernachten können aber es ist
wirklich nur arbeitsstätte frühstücken
einem kleinen tisch in den feierabend
[Musik]
die welt in der dieser bundestag
zusammen finden soll ist entgrenzt
globalisierung digitalisierung alles
wird unübersichtlicher komplexer nicht
nur daten und waren bewegen sich rund um
den globus auch menschen getrieben wird
kriege armut klimawandel viele staaten
reagieren mit abschottung
[Musik]
sozialer medien geben ein neues tempo
vor
auch politiker werden zu getriebenen
mehr information mehr desinformationen
was ist wahrheit was ist lüge
deutschland tritt entzweit durch die
einwanderungspolitik
auf der einen seite überschwängliche
hilfsbereitschaft
[Musik]
auf der anderen seite aggressive
ablehnung
debatte konsensfindung wären wichtig
doch ausgerechnet an dem ort der dafür
vorgesehen ist gibt es die jahrelang zu
wenig im letzten bundestag eine
koalition gehabt zwischen cdu csu und
spd das war als große koalition
die hatte bei vier fraktionen 80 prozent
der abgeordneten dann entsteht natürlich
so der eindruck
über viele fragen wird gar nicht so
diskutiert und auf dem höhepunkt der
flüchtlingskrise gab es praktisch keine
debatten im parlament über das für und
wider der aufnahme von fast einer
million flüchtlingen
die ist praktisch unterdrückt worden
weil alle mehr oder weniger in die
gleiche richtung gedacht und
argumentiert haben und das hat sich
später gerecht einen monat nach der wahl
der neue bundestag kommt zum ersten mal
zusammen mit sechs fraktionen zwei mehr
als vorher
frank müller rosentritt freut sich über
den wiedereinzug der fdp hans jörg
müller von der af de steht vor der
parlamentswahl ein mal erleben der erste
tag im deutschen bundestag das ist nur
heute das ist ein einmaliges erlebnis
und ich habe natürlich positiv ist ganz
gut und ich freue mich wahnsinnig darauf
[Musik]
demokratischer streit ist notwendig aber
es ist weit nach regeln
ich warne davor sonder regelungen zu
schaffen auszugrenzen oder gar zu
stigmatisieren
wir alle haben das gleiche man da durch
die wahl sind wir jetzt die
repräsentanten des volkes und der wille
des volkes von denen jahr alle
staatsgewalt ausgeht ist maßstab unseres
handelns dafür dass menschen aus
normalen leben ich angst hat mit der
höchsten volksvertretung mitzuwirken
sind generationen von mutigen menschen
vor uns ausgestanden haben viele mit
ihrem leben bezahlt dass das was ich
weiterleben darf überhaupt möglich ist
doch die arbeit kann auch nicht richtig
losgehen existieren klar wer opposition
wird und wer regierung
union fdp und grüne beginn zu sondieren
ob sie neues wagen sollen
jamaika beate müller gemmeke von den
grünen empfängt lobbyisten doch viel zu
besprechen gibt es noch nicht das ist
die kunst aber nicht zeit also wir sind
gewählt wir sind als fraktion
konstituiert wissen als bundestag
konstituiert und trotzdem gibt es ja
noch eigentlich überhaupt kein
parlamentarisches leben
müller gemmeke sozialpädagogin sitzt
seit 2009 im bundestag war zuletzt
grünen-sprecherin für arbeitnehmerrechte
im moment bleibt ihr nicht viel mehr als
der wöchentliche gang in die
fraktionssitzung
schwer vorstellbar dass ein ende nehmen
zu einem ende von mir alles vorstellen
in allen genres aber wie ist da
überhaupt man kommt es kommt gar nicht
jamaika platz die fdp steigt
überraschend aus
es ist besser nicht zu regieren als
falsch zu regieren
angela merkel bleiben jetzt nur zwei
machtoptionen eine minderheitsregierung
oder wieder ein bündnis mit der spd
die will aber nicht in eine große
koalition nicht zur verfügung
also alles auf anfang neuwahl
das staatsoberhaupt redet den
parteichefs ins gewissen
vor allem dem von der spd wer sich in
wahlen und politische verantwortung
bewirbt er darf sich nicht drücken wenn
man sie in den händen hält
kasan sowie da hinstellen und sagen du
kannst mich mal geht das nicht die spd
quält sich am lautesten trommeln die
groko gegner trotzdem entscheiden die
genossen doch noch mal mit der union zu
verhandeln wieder wochenlang nicht zeit
am ende steht eine koalition der
abgekämpften keiner der
verhandlungsführer wird noch lange
parteichef bleiben
[Musik]
ab
das war kein guter start für die
regierung aber auch nicht für den
deutschen bundestag und eigentlich ist
es eine koalition aus pflicht eine
koalition wider willen aber aus der
verpflichtung heraus diesem land eine
regierung zu stellen haben wir es doch
gemacht und dass das keine günstige
konstellation ist kann man daran
erkennen dass bisher zwei
parteivorsitzende und zwei
fraktionsvorsitzende ihr amt aufgeben
mussten
[Musik]
fünf monate nach der wahl macht der
bundestag angela merkel zur kanzlerin
zum vierten mal und die müllers
mittendrin
[Musik]
herr präsident ich nehme die wahl an ich
bin erstmal froh dass es dass wir jetzt
starten können und dass ich dann
hoffentlich beiden auch mein
gesetzentwurf auf dem tisch haben
[Musik]
die kanzlerin bekommt deutlich weniger
stimmen als ihre koalition zur verfügung
hat
kein gutes vorzeichen
was so ihre prognose hält das hätten sie
mich dass heute vor der kanzlerin wohl
gefragt hätte ich es auch erhält auf
alle fälle
jetzt bin ich mit skeptischer geworden
wenn es bei dieser kanzlerin im
bayrischen 35 stimme so großen kult zu
empfehlen
frage ich mich bei schwierige
entscheidung ganz aber ich bin
vorsichtig vorsichtig ob das ganze
dreieinhalb jahre hält so wahr mir gott
helfe
[Musik]
detlef müller macht ein praktikum
seit 2005 sitzt er im bundestag für die
spd wahlkreis chemnitz gebe ich meine
handynummer ab alle 14 tore kriegt ja
wunderbar gewaschen gebügelt zurück
jetzt erst mal wichtig zu gucken was
eigentlich dahinter steckt da gibt es
ihnen ein stück machen das ganz normal
bieten
müller ist gelernter lokführer eine
volkspartei muss beim volk sein findet
er seine spd steckt tief in der krise
glaubwürdigkeit haben auch vollkommen
eingebüßt sagt wir wollen mit den
verschiedenen wollten immer da gedreht
hat also große koalition ja nein
eintritt ins ministerium nein
als solcher geschichten und da wieder
vertrauen aufzubauen das ewig dauert es
noch lange dauern und dann gehört halt
dazu politik zu machen die die leute
verstehen also eine politik die leute
brauchen und was verstehen ob da
überhaupt was unser fertigungszeiten
statt weil ich für uns muss ganz ehrlich
sagen im sommer okay
weil wir machen eine videoüberwachung
die kommt jetzt flächendeckend im
schritt oder verletzter was bringen dann
ist ja so jeder die augen aufgehen
dürfen wir das gemacht hat wird er
genauso abgeurteilte straftäter hoch
[Musik]
chemnitz im frühjahr 2018 müller ahnt
nicht dass seine stadt bald alle
schlagzeilen beherrschen wird frank
müller rosentritt kommt auch aus
chemnitz heute eröffnet er sein
bürgerbüro in der innenstadt
[Musik]
die fdp hat ihnen den auswärtigen
ausschuss geschickt was bedeutet
dienstreisen um die welt auch die
familie kommt zur eröffnung
von ganz prächtig natürlich gedanken und
das alles überhaupt
also würde ich nicht hier stehen dann
könnte im juni getroffen und
sitzungswoche die erste juliwoche
sitzung war in der einzigen sitzung ist
verein woche die jetzt im juni ist bin
ich auch noch in moskau
wenn graf lambsdorff das heißt ich bin
jetzt in summe fünf wochen nicht zu
hause sondern habe aber irgendwie
frankendorf und das muss man einfach mal
sagen da kann man ihnen wird dann danke
das wirklich machen jetzt ein fußball
sein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ein keller im regierungsviertel
das parlament hat eine eigene
fußballmannschaft den fc bundestag über
70 abgeordnete kicken mit also den
letzten jahren eigentlich mit spielen
dann bin ich glaube zwei mal die
europameisterschaft gewonnen und im
letzten jahr hatten wir ein besonderes
spiel das war ein spiel gegen die
knesset in jerusalem auch mit 1 0
gewinnen können und das hat auch
diplomatisch sportlich auch ein gutes
ergebnis und das für uns immer ein
wichtiger punkt ist das binde ist
sozusagen der benefiz charakter
vielleicht als beispiel dass wir
häufiger geld einspielen für stiftungen
oder für dinge die im guten zweck also
immer auch das gute und nützliche
verbinden mit der möglichkeit des
bundestages ein bisschen werbung zu
machen
mitspielen will auch hansjörg müller von
der afd
er hat einen aufnahmeantrag gestellt und
wartet immer noch auf antwort
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der vereinsvorstand kommt zusammen
einziger tagesordnungspunkt der
mitgliedsantrag von hansjörg müller
[Musik]
prüfung machen das wollen wir nicht und
da stehen uns auch nicht zu aber es
natürlich so dass gerade in dem fall der
afd ist natürlich viele äußerungen in
der öffentlichkeit gab von kollegen
kollegen wo wir einfach sagen ja wir
haben werte und wenn wir sagen auch
seiner freundlichkeit gibt es bei uns
nicht
da können gewisse äußerungen die in der
öffentlichkeit aufgetaucht sind dann
durchaus mal bei der beratung der rolle
spielen
heute will ich aber nicht kapiert haben
braucht er nicht also geht das nicht
weil dann verlieren wir selbst um die
legitimität und das ist ja das was viele
wollen dass sie sagen guck mal an das
habe ich immer gesagt
und selbst beim fußball da wenn wir
ausgegrenzt mit spielen lassen oder
nicht
es ist die grundfrage nicht nur beim
fußball die entscheidung des fc
bundestag wird bald wellen schlagen
auch sie hat einen weit verbreiteten
namen nicht müller sondern ali mohammed
ali ist rechtsanwalt
zum ersten mal im bundestag für die
linke und kurz vor ihrer ersten rede
präsident kolleginnen und kollegen liebe
gäste arme menschen sterben früher
das ist wissenschaftlich bewiesen ihre
politik der sozialen spaltungen letzten
jahren hat diese entwicklung befeuert
sie und damit spreche ich nicht nur
union spd an sondern auch die grünen und
die fdp also die ganz große koalition
des sozialabbaus sie haben hartz 4 und
die ausweitung des bildungssektors zu
verantworten schluss damit dass die
interessen
schluss damit dass die interessen der
unternehmen besser geschützt werden als
die der verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
schluss mit der ausbeutung der
beschäftigten man kann sagen weil ich an
einigen stellen so wie dieses haben
früher mit dem ja es ist jetzt nicht
nach rechts gucken sehen sie dir auf die
gucken sie da überhaupt hin nehme ich
meine ich gucke da glaube ich nicht
die würden mich so auf und das ist dann
auch nicht gut miteinander dann will ich
immer einfach nur zurückführen aber das
ist ja auch nicht gut und ich kann mich
dann irgendwie nicht ich muss mich
zusammenreißen
okay machen das noch mal wir brauchen
die agrar und ernährungsmesse und wir
müssen sie mit einem sozialen aufbruch
verbinden
acht monate nach der wahl
der bundestags betrieb läuft an jetzt
das wort im kollegen frank müller
rosenwirth fc chelsea seinen ersten
deutschen bundestag
erste gesetze werden beraten auch die
müllers kommen zu wort
die behaupten die fdp nachher keine
politik für kleine leute sehr gerne frau
präsidentin meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren mehr verkehr auf die schiene
arme menschen sterben früher
es ist wissenschaftlich erwiesen worden
dobry dynamik us pendant sehen sie
selbst wie sinnvoll es ist deutsch ins
grundgesetz zu schreiben
flexible arbeitsverhältnisse sie dürfen
keine einbahnstraße sein denn die
beschäftigten brauchen soziale
sicherheit mit erlaubnis des präsidenten
nutze ich mal das als seine schau
beispiel was hat das einzige sich
schmeißen ist es immer
vielen dank
[Applaus]
[Musik]
den bundestag entschlüsseln und live im
fernsehen erklären
das ist sein job so residiert schärfer
von phoenix einmal für die
sprecherkabine bitte na das passt ja so
wir berufen uns jetzt hier mal so ein
bisschen ein und dann kriegt ihr den
abgleich der rednerliste und zur
jeweiligen funktionen
das kommentieren ist komplizierter
geworden mit mehr köpfe mehr reaktionen
versuchen wir mit jetzt der
bundestagspräsident es gibt eine
kurzintervention aus dem rheiner afd
wenig wie die hucke
präsident ratu kollegen er die zuschauer
auf den problemen vor allen dingen die
patrioten von peta dresden herzlich
willkommen im deutschen bundestag
herr kollege hilfe es schließt sich aus
ihrer rede nicht der zusammenhang
zwischen wölfen und migration vielleicht
könnten die technologie heute aber
natürlich mittlerweile wissen wir dass
überwiegend jungen männer zu uns kamen
über 80 prozent verfügen nicht über
deutschland benötigte bildung der
überwiegende teil die vom sozialstaat
und genau so läuft es beim wolf ohne die
menschen ja ja machen sie ruhig bei den
nächsten wahlen lassen wir es ist rauer
geworden ist es ein bisschen wildnis
wenn man so will im vergleich zu den
jahren davor gewesen sind wo es doch
relativ gesittet habe gegangen ist fast
wie im garten angelegt und jetzt das ist
glaube ich doch eher dschungel also man
weiß nicht was in bestimmten situationen
passiert man weiß nicht welche
reaktionen zu welchen anmerkungen kommen
und man weiß schon gar nicht was aus
reihen der afg kommt was auch immer
wiederum reaktionen auslöst also von
daher das gesittete geordnete und das
nur selten ausbrüche hatte wie das ist
weg ich kann ihnen sagen kopftuchmädchen
und alimentierte messer männer und
sonstige taugenichts werden unter in
deutschland
doch wachstum und noch allem den
sozialstaat nicht sicher
[Musik]
frau kollegin weiter damit
diskriminierend sie alle frauen die ein
kopftuch tragen positiv für ordnung
ja also wir beiden schon den sprach
korridor aus das ist ja auch mit unsere
aufgabe einfach die probleme zu benennen
so wie sie aus unserer sicht eben sind
in der vergangenheit war doch alles
alternativlos und seitdem wir da sind
werden die probleme endlich mal
angesprochen umbenannt von einer größten
deutschen kapitulation seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg zu sprechen das ist beschämend
dass solche worte hier im parlament
fallen von ihnen
ich schäme mich dafür die acht jetzt
nicht nur rassistisch und
nationalistisch nein die ist auch
militaristisch ja die abgeordnete von
der linken hat gerade die fdp als was
sich als rassistisch bezeichnet
dazu müsste jetzt genau hin zu gucken
wer jetzt klatscht der wirtschaft
demokratisch gewählte kollegen als
rassistisch und lift ich habe
wortmeldung außerhalb der fraktion
erklärte lassen sie eine zwischenfrage
zu mit rechtsradikalen und muss auch
nicht auf jede provokation mit einer
provokation antworten manchmal kann es
auch sinnvoll sein
etwas leer laufen zu lassen und man muss
auch dinge teilweise ertragen die
schmerzhaft sind für das eigene
empfinden aber die noch von der
meinungsfreiheit gedeckt sind
die sind über jedes stöckchen gesprungen
dass die hfg hinhält und das ist schon
deshalb falsch weil wir dadurch
sozusagen uns den weg verbauen über
andere wichtige themen zu reden
nächster redner thomas seitz für die
fdp-fraktion die asd provoziert sehr
geehrte frau präsidentin die fraktionen
der alternative für deutschland tritt
der kurzfristigen aussetzung der zusatz
punkte 5 und selbst 6 auf die
tagesordnung in gegen die vorgesehene
rede zeit widmen wir den gedenken an den
wiesbaden tot aufgefundene susanna wurde
14 jahre alt aus der erde kommst du und
zur erde wirst du werden
sie setzt eigenmächtig eine
schweigeminute an
es geht um einen mord an einer schülerin
den ein asylbewerber begangen hat darf
ich sie hinweisen dass wir gerade zur
geschäftsordnung reden und ich würde
auch bitten dass sie sich an die
vorgegebene tagesordnung und andy
geschäftsordnungsdebatte halten
[Applaus]
weshalb haben sie noch etwas zu sagen
ansonsten würde ich die nächste rednerin
und den nächsten redner aufrufen
da sie mir nicht antworten ist damit
ihre rede oder ihr beitrag beendet und
ich gebe das wort jetzt carsten
schneider für die spd und ich fordere
sie auf das redepult zu verlassen
jetzt sagen die regeln des bundestages
das schweigeminuten eben nicht von jedem
von einzelnen realisiert werden können
sondern die vom bundestagspräsidenten
von sitzungsleiter eingeleitet werden
diese wegen erkennen sie dann also nicht
an
es verträgt jedem abgeordneten wie er
seine redezeit nutzt und ja und in dem
fall war claudia roth zu dem zeitpunkt
bundestags vizepräsidentin und natürlich
lassen wir uns von frau roth am
wenigsten von frau roth zur
schweigeminuten irgend etwas
vorschreiben
ich muss mich natürlich als
sitzungspräsidentin an an die
geschäftsordnung halten und die
geschäftsordnung ist klar ist klar man
muss zur sache reden das heißt du kannst
dich über irgendwas einfach leben
tatsächlich schreibt die
geschäftsordnung vor ist ein redner
während einer rede dreimal zur sache
oder dreimal zur ordnung gerufen worden
so muss ihn der präsident das wort
entziehen
[Applaus]
schon wenige minuten später steht auf
den webseiten skandal
claudia roth stört das gedenken frank
müller rosentritt von der fdp erreichen
nachrichten aus dem bekanntenkreis
unverständnis über woods entscheidung
menschenleben und deren gedenken
unterliegen also an der geschäftsordnung
ihr seid so wie du dich gebunden solltet
euch in grund und boden schämen oder
halt mir fehlen da total die worte
unglaublich
da könnte ich noch einiges vor lesen in
dem verhandelt es sich wirklich um einen
möglichen persönlichen freund der ist
man werks meister also die kfd hat mit
ihrer mit dieser aktion die herzen
vieler menschen erreicht aber halt eben
leider mit falschen tatsachen
[Musik]
sepp müller von der cdu hat besuch eine
gruppe aus seiner alten schule in
sachsen anhalt zusammen mit
austauschschülern aus den usa vor zehn
jahren hätte müller hier selbst noch im
publikum gesessen
jetzt ist er der herr abgeordnete der
versucht eine beziehung aufzubauen
ich bin einer der wenigen abgeordneten
aber es werden immer mehr der unter
anderem online bürgersprechstunden
anbietet bei facebook macht ganz viel
über soziale medien insbesondere um eure
generation zu erreichen da wäre jetzt
übrigens gleich mal die frage angebunden
wer von euch ist noch wer liest von euch
noch mz das ist die mitteldeutsche
zeitung eine okay wer von euch ist bei
twitter facebook wo jesus facebook ok
instagram snapshot okay sind in diese
mühle aufgetragen hat es ziemlichen
druck auf sie aus also wie gehen sie
damit um vielleicht mit dieser kritik
die es in sich stellen müssen
es kommt natürlich darauf an wie
formuliert man kritik aber man muss sich
das auch als politiker erst mal annehmen
und gerade in den sozialen medien sinkt
die hemmschwelle immer mehr das bekomme
ich auch mit und das liegt meines
erachtens nach aber auch daran weil wir
uns viele jahre nicht erklärt haben und
das muss politik wieder machen
die politik muss die muss moderner
werden muss wie er das eigentlich auch
vorher offener werden transparenter
werden und jugend wird bestimmt von
sozialen medien verbringen
ich sage jetzt mal einfach 80 derzeit
auf sozialen medien würden kommt zwar
man ist zu hause meines langweilig man
scrollt durch instagram und wenn man
sich dann noch währenddessen mit politik
beschäftigen könnte das glaube ich die
perfekte mischung muss so sein wenn so
eine sitzung gibt wie zum beispiel am
donnerstag letzter woche von früh um
neun bis 148 in der nacht da ist man
natürlich die ganze zeit haben weil zum
beispiel eine landwirtschaftspolitik ist
dann sitzen wir finanzer und dann sind
die landwirtschaftsexperten jetzt darum
kommt immer die frage warum bist du der
bundestags- oder sein wo in der regel
nur die fachpolitiker da drin sitzen
[Musik]
das ist eigentlich das arbeitshaus des
deutschen parlaments ist paul löbe haus
darum auch wie ein achtzylinder
aufgebaut keinen diesel oder benziner ja
hier sind die ausschusssitzung seele
hier machen wir auch unsere
arbeitsgruppensitzung hier wird
gearbeitet hier wird richtig hart
miteinander und das was im plenum dann
stattfindet ist theater für diejenigen
die draußen sitzen an den
fernsehbildschirmen im internet das
verfolgen um einfach zu verfolgen ist
für was steht denn die linke für was
steht die fdp sieht die ccs müsse was er
versprochen dass nochmals das haben wir
so zum 9
[Musik]
das ist eine starke mikrofonanlage nach
einem wie man sie heute fast erfolgreich
um spiele die ukraine darf ich mich
herzlich bis heute zeit gefunden hat
aber wir wissen ja auch heutige zahlen
besonders fc diabetologie letzte
taktische besprechung des fc bundestag
dienstag sind meist noch keine plenums
debatten zeit für ein benefiz spiel der
gegner heute diabetes ärzte hansjörg
müller hat endlich post vom
vereinsvorstand bekommen eine ablehnung
die von ihnen bereits entrichteten
beiträge in höhe von 60 euro januar bis
märz werden umgehend nach der mit teilen
ihrer kontodaten zurück grüße ich war
zum vorgespräch bei vorstandsmitgliedern
des fc bundestages eingeladen gewesen
vor circa drei vier wochen das dahin
begann also herr müller das ist
natürlich kein tribunal aber in diesem
stil ist das gespräch schon gelaufen
man hat mich schlichtweg konfrontiert
wird meinen politischen ansichten und
die haben den leuten nicht gepasst
ein anderer abgeordneter der afg wurde
aufgenommen
warum hans jörg müller nicht mitspielen
darf darüber liegt das vereins geheimnis
die entscheidung ist umstritten
auch im team wir haben bedenken dass
unsere satzungsrechtlichen ziele das
erste fc bundestag nicht von hans jörg
müller entsprechend verkörpert werden
wie wir uns das als wertegemeinschaft
die wir hier alle auf dem platz stehen
vorstellen deshalb haben wir nicht
aufgeboten ich war damals bei der
entscheidung nicht dabei ich hätte beide
aufgenommen weil ich glaube dass man
hier nicht differenzieren sollte im
deutschen bundestag wäre dann am ende
spielt gegen wen spielt das entscheide
der captain
da kann man immer noch selektieren aber
vom grundsatz hätte ich würde ich keine
unterscheidung machen innerhalb des
parlaments haben sie denn vorher schon
mal jemanden auch nicht aufgenommen
also ich kann mich nicht erinnern eine
jährliche aber ich bin ja auch erst
zwölf jahren deutschen bundestag
[Musik]
den moralischen schwarzen peter für den
unzähligen missbrauch der sportsgeist
das den hatten den haben hier weinberg
möchte mir fühle und co für alle zeiten
an ihren händen kleben
ich finde es nur traurig wie man hier
auf übelste art und weise von seiten der
kartell parteien den sport auch noch als
waffe benutzt gegenüber uns ist einfach
nur noch traurig und ich freue mich
nicht über diese ausgrenzung auch wenn
es uns wahrscheinlich wieder nicht
[Musik]
grüße sie nehmen sie platz nichts was im
parlament passiert geht verloren alles
wird dokumentiert
dafür ist er zuständig christoph
wehmeyer einer von 30 bundestags
stenografen das monate gearbeitet habe
was schon mal sehr aufregen was man am
bundeskanzler vorbei zum arbeitsplatz
geht aber inzwischen ist es natürlich
für mich ganz normal geworden
[Musik]
der stimmung graf muss alles erfassen
wer applaudiert der ruf der zwischen und
was genau
die grünen machen
[Musik]
die kollegen gehören sie der rednerin zu
auf jeden fall ist es herausfordernd da
[Musik]
schon allein die tatsache dass wir sechs
fraktionen haben führt dazu dass wir ja
erst mal in der kürze der zeit eines
beifall zu erfassen müssen wer da
überhaupt platz statt in welcher
intensität und wenn da noch gleichzeitig
zurufe aus verschiedenen richtungen
kommen dann wird schon schwierig und
dann sind wir ganz froh dass wir dort
uns immer zu zweit sitzen was sie in
ihrem antrag fordern komma ist
verantwortungslos aus den notizen
entsteht das amtliche protokoll punkt
etwas anderes wer darin nach zählt
stellt fest dazwischen gerufen wird
jetzt mehr als früher
vor allem aber notieren die stenografen
viel mehr lachen und damit meinen sie
nicht heiterkeit die klammer zu wenn
jetzt einen redner spricht und erzählt
zum beispiel einen guten witz und es
gibt allgemeine heiterkeit im saal dann
ist das aber kein dieses lachen
das hat man so eine andere dimension das
ist eher ein höhnisches lachen
vielleicht auch eine faire lachen
das ist ein lachen das meistens vom
politischen gegner kommt und das
vielleicht so ein bisschen verächtlich
ist in richtung des redners diese leute
sprache als kulturgut im grundgesetz für
andere
unfassbar
die fdp fraktion
[Musik]
ehrlichkeit in der politik wird nichts
dieses verlachen war in den ersten zwei
jahren der letzten wahlperiode fast 600
mal zu hören
im gleichen zeitraum der jetzigen mehr
als dreimal so oft am häufigsten höhnte
die afg gefolgt von der spd und den
grünen
lachen und zwischenrufe sind erlaubt bei
persönlicher beleidigung ist schluss für
alle erwägungen die nachvollziehbar ist
der zuruf sie haben eine macke und
parlamentarisch ich habe eben den
zwischenruf pizzerien gehört den ruhig
das ist ja bestätigt dass hier aus der
fraktion die linke der zwischenruf nazi
k den muss flügen
man darf natürlich zum beispiel
bundestag sagen das ist diebstahl
wenn sie aber zu einem bestimmten
menschen sagen du bist denn du bist eine
beleidigung
deswegen gibt es dafür ein ordnungsruf
wenn sie sagen dass verleumdung
dann fällt es ohne die meinungsfreiheit
wenn sie sagen du bist ja dass sie sind
ein verleumder gibt es ein ordnungsruf
das ist dann mit der beleidigung
herr präsident ich das nicht wieder ein
ordnungsruf kläger also einen
wildgewordenen hühnerhaufen darf ich die
namen oder ich kann das nicht vor
absolut herr kollege kasse entscheiden
ich kann es erst entscheiden wenn sie in
sprechen tätig geworden sind da kann man
so sagen die afg ist wie ein
wildgewordener hühnerhaufen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jeder abgeordnete soll immer wieder sein
gewissen prüfen und entscheiden
blau für jahr rot für nein weiß für
enthaltung
der bundestag kommt in den arbeits modus
beschließt einen haushalt ein gesetz
dass sammelklagen ermöglicht der
familiennachzug für flüchtlinge wird neu
geregelt
so könnte es eigentlich weitergehen
[Musik]
doch dann legt ein knall al-islam mal
wieder innenminister seehofer droht mit
rücktritt
weil sein masterplan zur
flüchtlingspolitik nicht durchkommt
getrennte krisensitzungen von cdu und
csu
das hat es im bundestag noch nie gegeben
eine plötzliche regierungskrise die sich
immer weiter zuspitzt
[Musik]
in einer sonntag nacht kommt es zum
showdown
sepp müller zieht es in seinem büro das
kann ich noch nicht mal richtig
verhalten
das geht ja meine sache sagt thema
[Musik]
in dieser nacht fällt keine entscheidung
schon wieder around berlin von neuwahl
[Musik]
es wird nicht das letzte mal bleiben
detlef müller eine zur krisensitzung der
spd fraktion
er weiß nicht ob es am abend noch eine
regierung gibt für ihn geht in diesen
stunden viel kaputt
die summe ist uns vertrauen haben wenn
das thema massa waren als julias
vielleicht dann kommt vielleicht ein
rohbau am neckar und ob das seehofer das
alles gehöre und dann die neue sounds
skins weiß ja niemand
und dieses misstrauen mutter bleiben
[Musik]
einen abend später erklärt horst
seehofer die krise plötzlich für beendet
und sich selbst zum sieger das
regierungsbündnis ist aufgerieben und
damit beginnt für den bundestag die
parlamentspause die überschrift wird
nicht laut die afg hat das parlament
aufgelöst sagte überschrift wird lauten
die tradierten volksparteien sind dabei
sie selbst aufzumischen
denn das schauspiel was cdu/csu und was
spd auch als koalitionspartner in sich
selbst ortenberg und bietet das ist
wesentlich weitreichender in die
stabilität unseres gemeinwesens als das
was sie erreichen könnte schwieriger
antwort das könnt ihr eine überschrift
sein denn wir haben lange gebraucht bis
für die regierung gebildet haben und
dann ist die schwere die regierung
gekommen als wir gehofft haben das
könnte eine übersicht später mal sein da
war es schwieriger anfang sagt ja nicht
dass nicht das ende sehr gut wurde
[Musik]
der neunzehnte bundestag geht in seine
erste sommerpause mit der hoffnung dass
es besser wird im zweiten jahr beherztes
anpacken statt dauer krisen modus
zukunft gestalten findet das parlament
dafür die kraft am vorletzten
sitzungstag veranstaltet die spd
fraktion ein fest eingeladen sind auch
abgeordnete der anderen fraktionen außer
die der ard
[Musik]
angegeben sind sogenannte ganz offen als
begrüßungszeremoniell in der koalition
sind ja auch koalition
ich halte nichts davon jetzt immer in
depressiven phasen zu verfallen und die
sommerfeste sowas abzusagen weil alles
so ganz schwierig ist sondern immer
wichtiger um abzuschalten
mitten in der sommerpause schaut die
republik plötzlich nach chemnitz
während eines stadtfestes wurde ein mann
sturm tat verdächtigt zwei asylbewerber
7000 menschen gehen auf die straße
darunter auch gewaltbereite neonazis es
folgen ausschreitungen
[Musik]
eine woche später organisiert die afg
einen sogenannten trauermarsch durch
chemnitz extra aus bayern angereist ist
auch hans jörg müller
für mich ist der chemnitz heute ist das
gleiche wie erfurt damals 1989 der der
beginn der großflächigen bürgerproteste
gegen ein regime dem marsch ließen sich
auch rechtsextreme an
als die polizei die menge stoppt wegen
sicherheitsbedenken plötzlich aufrufen
[Applaus]
die fronten sind klar es gibt die guten
sind wir die demokraten es gibt die
bösen das in die regierungen die das
grundgesetz abgeschafft haben wie man
heute wieder mal sehen
jetzt sind die fronten gut und böse
geklärt denn jetzt weiß jeder was er zu
tun hat das ist schikane vor start
politik über die polizeiliche
einsatzleitung das ist dass merkel keine
regierung dass das merkel regime nach
dem muster das volk arrangierte
situationen hoch nicht mehr unendlich
ddr nicht mehr passieren in dem land
soll es so weit kommen dass die leute
trafen in der hand und für ihr recht
einträten
was dir passieren
hier stehen ja genau
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wenige tage später
der griff müller ist entsetzt von den
ereignissen in seiner stadt
er will ein zeichen setzen
nach dem grundgesetz sind geben wir euch
ein grundgesetz mit geben
ist wichtig deutschen grundgesetz
mitgeben kann man immer gebrauchen
das grundgesetz sie haben es nie
wegschmeißen reingucken lesen
grundgesetz brauchen sie doch es ist
alles gebrochen
ich bin ja auch nicht groß überrascht
also muss ich ja auch mal sagen haben
wir viele sachen geraten und wenn man
der stadt lebt und mit vielen leuten
redet ist man ja viele sachen bekannt
also jedes noch so gern wie die
stimmungslage ist
die gespräche werden jetzt sehr schnell
sehr grundsätzlich es geht um die
demokratie an sich die fragen aber auch
niemand mehr mitbestimmung vielleicht
noch mal mehr partie war bei der verkehr
aber ich frage wir fragen oder eine
straße bauen zum beispiel als wir 70 und
ewig lange dauert die
grundstückseigentümer ob das alles so
richtig ist und versuchen wir suchen
immer alle leute mitzunehmen
dann bereitet und redet muss rede was
hat sich ich kann es nur anbieten dass
sie kriegen wenn es ist einfach zum
irakkrieg und wie sie diese regierung
eigentlich
ich versuche und sie beschimpfen nicht
obwohl ich manchmal andere meinung haben
warum soll diese plugins eigentlich
alles gute
es gibt heute die stellen das system
kann auf eine inzwischen in frage die
haben ihre probleme mit der
bundesrepublik an sich dass das sind
sachen die mich beschäftigen
dass man jetzt 28 auch nach der wende
sorgen dieses ganze die ganze
freiheitlich demokratische grundordnung
disposition stellt das sind nicht nicht
viele aber trotzdem krieg ich dass er
mit und geräten auch mit mir und darüber
reden müssen wir morgen leute
zurückgewinnen für die demokratie
[Musik]
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine damen und herren
sie aber läge dann haben gestern gesagt
da innere frieden in unserem land sei
gefährdet ein riss geht durch unsere
gesellschaft aber sie die afg wollen wir
gar keinen inneren frieden in unserem
land sie reisen lesen wissen diesen
graben immer weiter auf das wird auch
heute im plenum wird er deutlich dass
hier ist das grundgesetz meine damen und
herren
lesen sie es schauen sie rein sie können
dabei fielen dann über menschenwürde
menschenrechte und demokratische kultur
vielen dank
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wollen sie uns verprügeln was wollen sie
denn machen sie haben schon lange den
demokratischen korridor verlassen hast
macht pässe schauen sich ein spiegel und
wenn sie dann jetzt auch noch gehen kann
man ihn nur eines großen liebe kollegen
unternehmen sind langsam mit der nehmen
sie platz nehmen sie platz in diesem
parlament wird gedroht geschwiegen der
saal verlassen
miteinander sprechen fast unmöglich
draußen formieren sich währenddessen
neue kräfte weltweite demonstrationen
für ein umsteuern in der klimapolitik
[Musik]
das mutterland der demokratie
erschüttert vom brh exit kraus das
parlament findet keinen ausweg
[Musik]
bei landtagswahlen in deutschland
verlieren die volksparteien weiter die
bundeskanzlerin sieht konsequenz ihren
weiten teilen sehr ordentliche
sacharbeit hatte bislang überhaupt keine
chance wahrgenommen zu werden
auf dem nächsten bundesparteitag werde
ich nicht wieder für das amt der
vorsitzenden der cdu deutschlands
kandidieren
zweitens diese vierte amtszeit ist meine
letzte als bundeskanzlerin die
regierungspartei cdu erlebt nie
dagewesen ist offenen wettstreit um den
parteivorsitz
[Musik]
sepp müller ist auf dem weg zum
entscheidenden parteitag sein favorit
als parteichef der konservativen
friedrich merz ich habe mir das heute
anschauen ich kenne drei alle drei
kandidaten mittlerweile auch schon durch
die tätigkeit hier unten hin und
bevorzuge jemanden das ist ganz klar der
nicht nur die steuererklärung auf dem
bierdeckel gemacht hat sondern natürlich
auch das wirtschaftsliberale bei uns
regt wo viele sich auch danach sehne ich
merke aber auch immer einer
mitgliederschaft und auch bei den
wählern dass sie sagen ja das ist der
richtige mann weil er auch die ganzen
jahre halten nichts mit dem politik mit
gewinnen berlins tun hat müller ist kein
delegierter darf nicht mitwählen
aber er wird dabei sein beim ende einer
ära es war mir eine große freude
es war mir eine ehre herzlichen dank
möchten sie den tag mitnehmen die
nachfolger wahl zieht sich müller
schmeißt derweil den bestand seiner
fraktion
die dürfen sie meinen persönlichen
newsletter also alles cool sie wird dann
machen
[Musik]
bio fisch egal wer jetzt gewinnt
da muss am ende den laden zusammenhalten
also ich gehe davon aus dass knapp
friedrich merz
so darf ich die frauen glücklich machen
sie sind aus hinein
ja dann ist es ja noch besser dass sie
finden dann wissen wer die stärksten
beste fraktion im deutschen bundestag
auf jeden fall die stärkste und tollsten
fraktion im deutschen bundestag wir
haben spaß wir anderen ja genau ich
liebe meinen job
so gibt es noch stimmzettel nämlich
eingesammelt
irgend ein delegierter nicht die chance
gehabt zu wählen
[Musik]
friedrich merz empfehlen 482 stimmen das
sind 48 25 prozent der stimmen und auch
annegret kramp karrenbauer entfielen 517
stimmen dass in 51,75 damit ist sie zu
neuen parteivorsitzenden der cdu gewählt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
im champions league finale als finalist
fest steht und hofft dass seine
mannschaft gewinnt am ende als zweiter
sieger den platz verlässt das man
natürlich erstmal enttäuscht das ist
ganz klar
jetzt heißt es nach vorne blicken weiter
trainieren weiterkämpfen für das nächste
champions league finale und das sind die
nächsten wahlen die anstehenden da
müssen wir 40 prozent kommen wir müssen
jetzt weiterarbeiten
was wissen sie so sagen warum muss ich
das so sagen davon überzeugt
[Musik]
ja das ist früh 7 7 und 25 muss ich ein
bisschen beeilen parlamentarisches
frühstück jahren da muss ich jetzt an
amira mohammed ali von der linkspartei
ist mittlerweile angekommen im
parlamentsbetrieb gerade auf dem weg zu
einem parlamentarischen frühstück das
heißt expertenvorträge bevor die
ausschusssitzungen starten
das essen ist nur nebensache vor beginn
feilt sie mit ihrer büroleiterin an den
nächsten rede
es geht um gesunde ernährung
[Musik]
jeder abgeordnete ist mitglied in
mindestens einem der 24 fachausschüsse
hier findet die eigentliche arbeit statt
entscheidungen vorbereiten experten
anhören detailarbeit
amira mohammed ali ist gleich in zwei
ausschüssen ordentliches mitglied
verbraucherschutz und landwirtschaft
beide tagen zeitgleich das heißt viel
arbeit und schnelles umschalten
was im leben der menschen an das finde
ich es nicht also ehrlicherweise
natürlich ist das manchmal schon weil
man sich sehr viel mit den anträgen
macht und mit gesetzentwürfen und dann
werden wir somit einem mit einem
federstrich ach ich bin im falschen
federstrich und wieder vom tisch
gewischt
aber ich stelle mir vor was denn wäre
wenn die opposition nicht auf ihre die
regierung einfach unkontrolliert machen
kann was sie will oder das kritisch
hinterfragt wird und dass sie mit
unseren anträgen eben debatten anstoßen
und egal wie da wird mir klar warum
macht und wichtig ist immer da für die
sicherung nicht mehr
[Musik]
darüber mal zeit messen
frank müller rosentritt hat großes vor
weil das ist jetzt einfach ganz schön
viel gestrichen und geändert und
ok-präsident liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen shalom das von deutschland
ausgegangen da für keinen von uns in
diesem hohen hause jeweils zur debatte
stehen er will deutschlands verhalten
auf der weltbühne verändern bisher
stimme die bundesregierung bei den
vereinten nationen zu oft gegen israel
dagegen will er etwas tun mit einer rede
einem antrag am liebsten mit einer
abstimmung im bundestag
jedes jahr verabschieden die vereinten
nationen mehrere resolutionen gegen
israel als gegen alle anderen staaten
dieser welt zu sammeln
das ist doch völlig absurd geben sie der
bundesregierung geben zu der
bundesregierung heute unsere
bundesregierung dafür geben sie der
bundesregierung ein dafür ein starkes
mandat haben die stilistisch alles ganz
plötzlich war das gleiche zu sagen
konnten
aber das wäre jetzt mal du bittest
entwurf
ich habe jetzt einen strich habe gestern
gestrichen wie alt man lässt was er wird
normativer was du die ersten zeitungen
werden auf müller rosentritt engagement
aufmerksam
das zählt viel für einen
oppositionspolitiker
das kann sicher nicht schaden man sagen
mit einem thema im deutschen bundestag
verbunden wird das gelingt tatsächlich
nicht jedem sind selber überrascht dass
bisherige okay das thema elektro müssen
sie kommen um daraus zu machen die frage
ich mich auch
[Musik]
denn
carrupt nehmen und mit franz brüchen
oppositionsarbeit im bundestag
beate müller gemmeke kennt das seit zehn
jahren
[Musik]
sie hat einen hebel für sich entdeckt
ich möchte ich heute von einem
arbeitskreis abstimmen lassen damit sie
eingereicht werden kann
jeder abgeordnete kann der regierung
schriftlich fragen stellen
mit unterstützung seiner fraktion das
ziel missstände aufdecken widersprüche
herausarbeiten aufmerksamkeit erzeugen
diesmal will müller gemmeke wissen was
die regierung für langzeitarbeitslose
plant 21 fragen
und wie gesagt ich mache es gern und es
ist auch wirklich ein ein wichtiges
instrument für uns in der opposition
es ist einfach eine gute möglichkeit
sich einer satten dem thema zu
beschäftigen
aber natürlich auch die bundesregierung
ein bisschen in verlegenheit zu bringen
innerhalb von 14 tagen muss die
regierung antworten schriftlich über die
ergebnisse berichten dann manchmal die
medien
die opposition ist größer geworden
aktiver in der ersten hälfte der letzten
wahlperiode gab es knapp 2000 anfragen
in dieser wahlperiode waren es bisher
fast dreimal so viel
das parlament wird selbstbewusster
situation dass sie mind fragen der
abgeordneten also über fragen
kontrollieren wir die bundesregierung
nicht beantworten zu müssen verspätet
beantworten zu können oder bestimmte
informationen und vorzuenthalten
wir haben inzwischen sehr deutlich
gemacht dass wir uns im interesse aller
mitglieder des bundestages eine solche
verzögerungstaktik die ja auch darauf
hinausläuft bestimmte informationen
nicht rechtzeitig zur verfügung zu
stellen um bestimmte entscheidungen
vielleicht in die eine oder andere
richtung zu beeinflussen nicht bieten
[Musik]
sepp müller von der cdu ist karnevalist
sein kostüm natürlich auch politisch sie
müssen ja wir hatten da eine debatte zum
wolf im bundestag und da habe ich mich
sehr eindeutig positioniert das schlug
wellen nicht nur im sozialen medien und
dabei nicht schonen das mandala auch auf
dieses ernste thema mit einem lächeln
drauf schauen sollen sich selber mal auf
die schippe nehmen kann und deswegen der
rolfshäger mit rotkäppchen und dem wolf
[Musik]
wenn sie zum beispiel in annaburg in die
kita ihr kind bringen 200 meter vor dem
wolf spazieren geht dann kann man noch
so ein wolfspaar sein da wird ihnen
schon angst und von den ganzen
münsterischen ball ganz zu schweigen
ein kaltes bier bestellt und ich hoffe
es richtig stimmen hat er gesehen
[Musik]
aber die richtig ordnung ist es bei
ihnen sind sie aus dem karnevalsfan ich
bin jetzt nur durch ihn zum karneval
gekommen
ansonsten halte mich etwas fern davon
gehalten musste er sich überreden dass
sie zu machen alles freiwillig
das ist ja ein thema was emotionalisiert
gibt es anfeindungen ja
also wie sabine relativ wenig da kann
man sachlich argumentieren und ich habe
es hier natürlich auch wenn jemand eine
andere meinung hat das muss man dann
sollte man auch in einer demokratie
aushalten
in den sozialen medien angefangen von
beleidigungen bis hin zum motto anstatt
dass der wolf das fadenkreuz auf sicher
hat hast du es demnächst zwischen den
anschlussstellen was macht das mit ihm
vor zwei jahren also vor
vor dem wahlkampf hätte ich mich darüber
tierisch geärgert
mittlerweile friedman und predigte ab ob
das gut ist weiß ich nicht dass die
diskussionskultur ist die man sich
wünscht also ich wünsche mir die mich
[Musik]
flyer und handydaten verfasst browser
schmecken lassen
bitteschön das können sie gerne
mitnehmen das ist grundgesetz ja sollte
detlef müller am tag vor der kommunal
und europawahl auf einem stadtteilfest
in chemnitz gibt es zusammenfasst brause
und grundgesetz jetzt will sie mit einem
grundgesetz und fassbrause gut in den
umfragen triumphiert die afc müller spd
liegt weit zurück
aber er sieht das positive
sie haben normal und die ersten 300
zweck innerhalb von zwei tagen also am
fahren und kommt gesetzt ein mann
gebracht
im chemnitzer das finde ich gut das ist
wichtig und die leute können ja selber
werden zudem verlangen nach den gründen
gesetzen finden das ja vom humor so
schön man muss einfach mitnehmen kann
und das denke ich schon eine gute sache
[Musik]
bitteschön nicht abheben
wahlabend
die ersten hochrechnungen kommen für
müllers spd kommt es noch schlimmer als
gedacht
[Musik]
kattas
kastels vorstellung zeit investiert visa
gewinner sind diejenigen die nicht
volkspartei sein wollen
die keine kompromisse nötig haben die
machen dann machen die bienen
beziehungen ist emotional und deshalb
getroffen
das kann doch nicht hier arbeiten das
finde ich alles gut verläuft
es gibt eine paradoxe situation die
politischen probleme werden immer
komplexer klimaschutz migration handel
globalisierung der wunsch nach einfachen
lösungen wird gleichzeitig immer stärker
das funktioniert aber nicht wir dürfen
die fähigkeit in unserer demokratie
nicht verlieren egal wie sich jetzt das
parteiensystem verändert dass wir
tatsächlich auch dicke bretter bohren
können und an langfristigen lösungen
arbeiten und durch die sozialen medien
wird natürlich der wunsch nach einfachen
lösungen noch mal verstärkt bei der
permanent mit ganz kurzen botschaften
suggeriert wird was richtig oder falsch
ist
tage später zurück in berlin unter woche
haben wir ungefähr 150 solcher
glückwunschschreiben die nicht quasi im
erzgebirge und vogtland mittel sagt
erkenntnis versenden da herr fuchs zum
beispiel aus schönheide
er hat jetzt zum beispiel 100 jähriges
firmenjubiläum und es ist ja auch nicht
so halten das ist ja auch eine seit
jahren eine firma machen und ich denke
dazu kam noch mal trainieren und sagen
mensch super coole sache dass sie
irgendwie es geschafft haben irgendwie
durchsetzt dass sie bei der
fleischerinnung wieder mit gold und
silber probiert wurden sie zwar einen
schwarzen berg zum beispiel ich habe 90
jähriges jubiläum
die bürger reagieren den 99 prozent der
fälle sehr sehr positiv und oft ist es
so dass es für viele der erste brief ist
von dem abgeordneten regionen und sagen
halt bin ich heute tag lasse das sicher
wahrgenommen werde
das abnehmen partei folgen
es geht um jeden bürger also das ist das
ist also wenn's dann parteifreunden
geben da man die briefe in einem brief
an sachsens million
müller rosentritt ist mitglied im
auswärtigen ausschuss spezialgebiet
asien das bedeutet ständiges pendeln
zwischen berlin chemnitz und der welt
keinen problemen dieser welt von der
größe kennt ja fast schon sicher stehen
und meine frau haben am gleichen tag
geburtstag ist theater führung 3
viel zu selten
[Musik]
politik neu denken digitalisierung ist
alles was ändert sich die politik mit
dem namen gibt
[Musik]
wie zufrieden sind sie mit ihrem leben
derzeit
[Gelächter]
das leben aktuell ist unglaublich
spannend das geht unglaublich schnell
man kann damit mehr als zufrieden sein
weil es gibt es ist für mich immer noch
ein unglaubliches gefühl von größter
demut mitglied in diesem deutschen
bundestag sein zu dürfen und deshalb bin
ich damit tatsächlich total glücklich
endlich wirklich der spagat zwischen
familie wahlkreis auslandsreisen hier
vor ort immens ist das ist ja derzeit
die die kommt ja nicht wieder bei
kindern ja juli verpassen sie jetzt ja
also das ist so aber am ende ist so ein
demokrat zu einer demokratie lebt ja nur
von demokraten man kann ja nicht sagen
ich lebe jetzt in einem staat in einer
gesellschaft ist demokratisch und es
gibt niemanden dass die demokratisch
engagiere
ein lang wie unser land was quasi von
den bürgern selbst gestaltet wird und
ich bin eine davon kann nur
funktionieren wenn es menschen gibt die
sich für andere bürger einsetzen
das klingeln kommt vom bundestags
alarmsystem irgendwas ist groß drüben im
plenarsaal einheimischen dass sich alle
den saal verlassen und nur durch die
türen auf der gegenüberliegenden seite
wieder hereinkommen können wir haben
dort drei türen ja nein und enthaltung
dann bitte ich mit der abstimmung zu
beginnen woher der name hammelsprung
kommt ist unklar
es geht um die beschlussfähigkeit des
parlaments dabei kommt es auf die
anwesenheit jedes einzelnen an
[Musik]
ist noch eine kollegin kolleginnen
außerhalb des saals der abstimmung
teilnehmen möchte der möge bitte jetzt
durch die tür
[Musik]
naja
schließen sie die tür in die anstellung
ist geschlossen
müller rosentritt erreicht den saal ganz
knapp arme sprünge sind gedacht als
ausnahme jahrzehntelang wurden
beschlüsse auch dann gefasst wenn das
plenum nicht voll besetzt war
abgeordneter arbeiten auch in
ausschüssen sitzungen sind im gespräch
mit bürgern im büro seit 2017 werden sie
auffällig häufig zum hammelsprung
herbeigerufen oft beantragt von der afg
auch deren reihen sind nachts um 1 uhr
36 gelichtet frau präsidentin die afg
fraktion bezweifelt die
beschlussfähigkeit der versammlung
gemäß paragraf 45 absatz 2 der
geschäftsordnung bitte ich um
überprüfungen es geht hier um die
beschlussfassung über ein sehr wichtiges
gesetzespaket und es kann nicht sein
dass wir hier mit rund 100 anwesenden
ein gesetz dieser güte und dieser
schwere beschließen
also wir haben hier oben miteinander
diskutiert wir sind der meinung dass die
beschlussfähigkeit gegeben ist brauchen
sie haben jetzt keine möglichkeit wir
haben uns jetzt so entschieden sie
bringen
wir führen wir gehen jetzt fort in der
sitzung des parlaments
ich vermute zunehmend dass es auch darum
gibt den bundestag als demokratische
institution das parlament das herz der
demokratie als parlament immer wieder
lächerlich zu machen immer wieder
vorzuführen
und es geht ja nicht darum dass man eine
möglichst lebendige oder konstruktive
streitkultur im parlament hat sondern es
geht tatsächlich darum zu drangsalieren
wir wollen dass deshalb damit wir eine
beschlussfähigkeit des bundestages die
ja auch gesetzlich oder durch die
geschäftsordnung auch vorgegeben ist
eingehalten wird weil wichtige
gesetzespaket
zuletzt gab es ja im hammelsprung vor
ihrer fraktion wo sie dann sehr wenige
rahmen das deute darauf hin dass es
nicht nur um die beschlussfähigkeit geht
sondern das ist auch so eine art symbol
ist dass er da setzen
nein das gilt natürlich auch für unsere
eigenen fraktion das ist natürlich
völlig klar
meine frage gibt es noch einen kollegen
oder eine kollegin die noch nicht die
stimme abgegeben hat anwesenheit von
anfang bis ende
hansjörg müller von der afg hält das für
eine illusion
er verlässt das gebäude mittlerweile
regelmäßig vor 22 uhr also ich habe da
meine ganz persönliche meinung dazu das
geht von 9 uhr früh mit der
unterbrechung jetzt laut plan bis 1 uhr
25 dann dauert es wahrscheinlich wieder
eine stunde länger als man bei halb drei
morgens früh um halb neun ist die
nächste sitzung um 9 uhr ist an plenum
also sorry kein mandat dieser erde kann
uns unsere gesundheit zurückbringen
herzinfarkt schlaganfall alles was hier
die folgen sind von dieser art horror
tagesplan
das können meinetwegen die machen die
diesen plan erstellt haben aber ich gehe
um zähler nach hause weichen rechthaber
auszuschlafen recht habe auf meiner
gesundheit detlef müller hat jetzt oft
nachtschicht seine fraktion hat einen
dienstplan eingeführt es sollen immer
genügend spd leute im plenarsaal seien
auch für den fall dass mal wieder ein
hammelsprung verlangt wird neue zeiten
vor der neue ideen und viel kraft ich
habe ganz am anfang ist auch die
legislatur wurde ebenso spannend sein
wie das bundesrätliche erlebt hat und es
ist genauso willkommen
das ist wirklich so vondra schwierige
regierungsbildung mit vielen vielen
konflikten auch innerhalb der fraktion
und parteiführung und fraktionsführung
also auch personelle geschichten bis hin
zu den ganzen brauchen die meisten große
koalition ja nein kanzlerin gramm kaum
bauern sind ja in allen ecken baustellen
das ist schon spannend
sepp müller hat seine online
sprechstunden ausgebaut
er berichtet über seine arbeit
beantwortet aktuelle fragen an diesem
tag geht es auch um den mord am kasseler
regierungspräsidenten walter lübke
seit zwei jahren ist müller jetzt im
parlament die demokratie sieht er
gefährdete als früher
der kompromiss wovon politik auch lebt
dass man sich aufeinander zu bewegt und
gemeinsam nach vorne zu kommen und wenn
es nur ein kleiner schritt ist es
wahrscheinlich anscheinend nicht mehr up
to date es geht nur noch um rechts oder
links oder volle oder unten das geht nur
noch um die einfachen antworten auf
schwierige fragen da muss man sich schon
möglich die frage stellen wie gehen wir
miteinander um
amira mohammed ali hat eine neue
tradition immer nach einer rede von ihr
gibt es törtchen für alle mitarbeiter 21
mal stand sie in den vergangenen zwei
jahren am pult am anfang hatte sie sich
vorgenommen von dort nicht zu af.de
rüber zu schauen
die sie immer noch genauso auf wie am
ersten tag
ja sagen bei der afg hat sich bei mir
überhaupt keine normalität eingestellt
aber was schon der fall ist im plenum
markiert man nicht nicht mehr so also
tatsächlich ist es da am anfang hat man
immer das gefühl möchte noch immer was
dazwischen rufen und was darauf erwidern
und das hört wird irgendwann weniger
wochen genau aus dem motto wenn's auch
katja ist dass das wollen die ja nur
dann
[Musik]
wenn sie den vergangenen zwei jahren und
der überschrift geben müssten oder so
auf einen nenner bringen müssen wie sie
die erlebt haben haben sie da eine
überschrift erfolgreiche
oppositionsarbeit und erschreckende
inkompetenz und kabinett also diese zwei
jahre waren politisch schon sehr extrem
es war wie eine achterbahnfahrt wir
erleben erstmals in deutschland wie wir
mit schwierigen extremen politischen
situationen in politisch umgehen müssen
man braucht einfach auch ein bisschen
gelassenheit und ruhe und konzentration
auf das wichtige dornröschen ist
aufgewacht der bundestag ist aufgewacht
jetzt geht es um den kernbestand unserer
demokratie und der bundestag sozusagen
herzkammer der demokratie die ausschüsse
des deutschen bundestags die
maschinenräume der demokratie die müssen
diese herausforderung annimmt wir haben
relativ viel von dem was da nach einem
schwierigen anfang vereinbart worden
sich auf den weg gebracht ja sind
intensiv an der arbeit aber wir sind in
einer welt voller atemberaubend
schneller veränderungen also keine
fertigen überschrift für die jetzigen
nein ich gebe ihnen die überschrift für
diese legislaturperiode am ende der
wahlperiode oder sagen sie ständiger
wandel
[Musik]
[Applaus]